foreign
so when we were at the Sunday Symposium
this last weekend which by the way you
can join us sundaysymposium.com it's in
Los Angeles once a month
I came up with this rule someone was
asking a question about hey we're
getting ready to move to Los Angeles
we've got all this stuff and Ryan was
talking about oh we've got the
minimalist rule book 16 rules for living
with less you can Implement some of
these rules like the spontaneous
combustion rule or the 90-90 rule the
seasonality rule or the Justin Case rule
or the just for win rule or the
emergency items rule we have 16
different rules in there you can even
play the 30-day minimalism game you can
download the free calendar on our
website theminimalists.com and you can
play this little friendly competition
together and I came up with this new
rule recently I call it the didn't know
Rule and here's how it goes if you find
something you didn't know you owned you
can give yourself permission to let go
and how often does this happen because
we have so many things every
American has 300 000 items in their home
on average of course there are some
things that you own you you forgot you
owned it right oh I didn't even know I
still had that I didn't even know we
ever had this I didn't know we owned
that I didn't know we had this I didn't
know we had this we find something in
the Attic we find something in the
basement we find something in the garage
or the storage locker or some box that's
tucked away in the closet huh I didn't
know I owned that well that's
functionally like not owning it and if I
didn't know I owned something that is
the perfect time for me to give myself
permission to let that thing go
um
man hey that's so good say that uh say
that pity python whatever you want to
call it say that say that pipey uh thing
you led with again all right so here's
the pithy thing yeah if you find
something you didn't know you owned you
can give yourself permission to get rid
of it
hey why how do you not know you own
something right
he's talking about when you come across
and you're like oh
I didn't even know I owned that thing I
know but how do you get there because we
accumulate things just in case
and we hold on to him just in case and
eventually we forget about those things
because that in case never comes and
then eventually you come across it when
you're moving and you're like oh yeah I
forgot I bought that thing because I
thought maybe one day I would want to
wear that Speedo at the beach
I totally forgot I even owned that
Speedo I can get rid of it now TK I
think you should
took the Lord's Spirit on you man that
is your color now Ryan you were um
Amnesia produced by excess so it's such
an interesting I love that band
it's a Radiohead spin-off fan and what
you were talking about there is in case
never happens so if in case never
happens what happens you have a thing
that is just it's just sitting there
it's just taking up space it's just in
the way we have all of these things that
we've amassed quite often they're just
given to us here you have this you have
this we get these free things these
chachkies we buy something because it's
on sale and all of a sudden I'm holding
on to it I'll just put it here I'll tuck
it away for later I'll hold on to it
just in case and then we have hundreds
of thousands of just in case items in
our home and that's when we realized I
didn't even know I owned it or I didn't
I didn't know I still have that thing or
maybe my wife brought something home and
she's not thinking about it anymore I've
never given it much thought and now it's
just sitting there and so if I didn't
know I still own the item I can give
myself permission to Let It Go
I got a list here of 12 things
that I own I just love your listicles
that aren't very minimalist
man
and I would really call this the problem
with duplicates but it's not really a
problem because I own these 12 things
I own two toothbrushes we've talked
about this when we did the house tour
once I showed you my junk drawer and so
I keep a toothbrush in my junk drawer
which is very nicely organized junk
drawer in fact we turned that into a
YouTube video you can find that over at
uh youtube.com the minimalist so you
tore my minimalist junk drawer and when
you see that junk drawer there's a
toothbrush in there but of course I have
a toothbrush in my bathroom as well now
why do I have that it's a there's a
practical use for that and so this is
where minimalism comes in handy because
minimalism isn't saying well I guess I
should only have one thing otherwise
it's waste otherwise it's stupid
otherwise it's wrong or otherwise it's
not very minimalist of you well I have a
separate toothbrush in the kitchen
because that's where I brush my teeth in
the mornings I get up before my wife and
I don't want to wake her up and so if
I'm brushing my teeth in the bedroom
which is right or the bathroom right
next to our bed it's a huge problem
because it's going to wake her up most
more she's a fairly light sleeper so I
go out into the kitchen I brush my teeth
out there and I have a second toothbrush
in order to do that and that way she is
not disturbed by my incessant brushing
by the way he's like the Floyd
Mayweather of toothbrushes I heard an
interviewer ask Floyd why do you have
two girlfriends and he says because one
is too close to none
and that's that's how Josh is he's the
Floyd Mayweather of toothbrushes I just
want to say I keep completely different
things in my drunk drawer
this is what we're talking about right
it's all these little tiny bottles yeah
they're empty
the drunk drawer turned into a jump
drawer oh I'm a one woman man and a one
toothbrush brusher
there you go minimalists
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free